dans le vignoble rivière du chêne
on se prépare déjà au vent dans ce
domaine vient de doubler sa superficie
il dispose maintenant de 36 hectares
emploie près de 40 personnes et produit
quelques trois cent mille bouteilles par
an comme on n'est pas souvent en rupture
de stock mais faut gérer nos inventaires
faut gérer notre croissance
comme j'ai précisé c'est une industrie
pratiquement naissante naissante
on juge qu'on va doubler nos surfaces de
6 5 à 10 ans au cours des cinq dernières
années l'industrie viticole québécoise à
doubler sa production annuelle de
bouteilles et le nombre d'hectares de
vignes cultivées c'est un tsunami dont
800 hectares actuels un peu plus de
sanvignes avec pignon sur rue et 2.5
millions bouteille qu'on produit on veut
remonter notre objectif c'est 10
millions de bouteilles pour 2030
le succès des vins québécois s'explique
par plusieurs phénomènes
ils n'ont cessé de gagner en qualité ils
séduisent une clientèle de plus en plus
jeune et il profite d'une meilleure
distribution dans les épiceries et les
succursales de la société des alcools du
québec c'est les jeunes millénium qui
ont mille le spot sur notre industrie
sur la qualité de nos vins et l'autre
toutes les générations en ajoute tout
d'un coup les vignerons ont investi 10
millions de dollars dans leur domaine
pour les agrandir et les protéger des
rigueurs de l'hiver
ils se tournent maintenant vers le
gouvernement québécois pour qu'ils
investissent lui aussi dans cette
industrie en plein développement
il faut avoir des aides à la plantation
pour nous aider à développer justement
cette viticulture au québec parce que
c'est une culture qui valorise également
notaire comme elle crée énormément
d'emplois
ses créateurs de beaucoup de bonheur et
il va falloir que le gouvernement
réalise que c'est sa responsabilité
sociale que de supporter ces
entrepreneurs à créer de la richesse
pour partager ce bonheur là dans notre
société
ils vont quirion crois que la
viticulture québécoise est promise à un
très bel avenir
j'ai l'impression qu'on est un nouveau
vignoble très innovateur très très
intelligente dans sa démarche qui veut
vraiment réellement écologique faut
qu'on soit transparent et honnête parce
qu on compétitionne 15000 vins étrangers
on peut pas être autre chose que nous
des vins authentiques et de qualité donc
qui n'ont pas fini de séduire bien des
palais et si catherine françois
radio-canada saint jacques le mineur